pas très bon soir ça peux tu me dire que
les insultes qui t'a fait le plus mal
c'est une insulte que j'entends souvent
malheureusement c'est quand on écrit
patrick ça je supporte pas parce que
j'ai peur qu'on le confonde avec
quelqu'un d'autre avec patrick sabatier
patrick sébastien et je tiens à lire ce
soir mon prénom c'est quand même maurice
quoi maurice qu'est ce que tu as de plus
sexy en toi pour certaines c'est ma voix
cassé ma voix café maurice qu'est ce que
tu écris quand on me demande des
autographes
j'ai envie d'écrire des tas de choses
arrive d'écrire je t'aime c'est super
c'est génial c'est finalement je n'ai
rien à dire parce que le fait qu'on me
demande d'autographe examen s'est suffi
quoi y'a rien à ajouter c'est déjà super
est-ce que tu thème souvent je me pose
cette question quand même atteint dans
la glace et je dis ce que je suis en
adéquation avec moi-même et finalement
il ya des jours oui ce jour non mais
depuis quelque temps on y chante j'ai
vraiment trouvé un personnage avait
vraiment à coeur qui s'est révélé que
j'aime beaucoup
maurice tu crois qu'il faut coucher pour
réussir je pense pas mais je pense qu'il
faut réussir pour coucher c'est vrai dis
moi c'est pas dur de devenu une star au
moment du sida je veux que toute façon
le star system sais c'est un formidable
préservatif ça vous préserver quelque
chose entre république et vous qui se
passe qui est complètement platonique et
ça c'est grand c'est beau et je pense
qu'en courent pas de risques
quand as-tu pleurer pour la dernière
fois j'ai pleuré à montpellier je crois
ou à bordeaux chez plus fins sont des
personnes mangent à toulouse en fait
c'était comment j'avais envie de pleurer
j'ai pleuré dans ma loge et je serai
aussi devant biarritz car je tiens à le
dire et après demain je veux être avant
du son je crois que je peux réussir tu
préfères draguer ou de faire draguer je
n'ai pas le choix toute façon on mènera
tous les soirs
c'était 15000 à bordeaux sera 12000 à
montpellier qui me draguent ce fossé su
c'est quelque chose qui nous dépasse
quoi ce n est pas empêché à montluçon
ils sont combien chat qui seront passés
de 12000 incarcération ils sont tout
moment pascal et on laisse entrer des
gens à la fin c'est la fête quoi c'est
génial c'est à quoi reconnaît-on
infailliblement la passion naissante la
patience et cesser la flamme cesser la
flamme d'un briquet qu'on allume coincé
et puis être simple briquet plus être
patient et puis plus la couche d'ozone
six ans maintenant et la passion qui
s'éteint c'est quand y'a plus de gaz
merci morice
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux